whay is early Chinese term that means
literally no doing or no trying but I
think a better translation is effortless
action and it's the central spiritual
ideal for these early thinkers I look at
so the Confucians and the Daoists and
what it looks a little bit like flow or
being in the zone as an athlete so
you're you're very effective you're
moving through the world in a very
efficient way the social world and
physical world well you don't have a
sense of doing anything you have a sense
of effort you don't have a sense of
yourself as an agent you kind of lose
yourself in the activity you're involved
in and you're not only efficacious in
terms of skill in the world you also
have this power that the early Chinese
call unfortunately the Mandarin
pronunciation is duh it sounds kind of
funny but it's a often translated virtue
or mean something like charismatic power
charismatic virtue it's this energy you
kick off in aura that you kick off when
you're in a state of way and this is why
these early thinkers want way because
for both of them the Confucians and the
Daoists
it's the key to political and spiritual
success so if you're a Confucian getting
into a state of way gives you this power
and this allows you to attract followers
without having to force them or try to
get them to follow you people just
spontaneously want to follow you if
you're a Taoist it's what relaxes people
put some it ease and allows you to move
through the social world effectively
without harm so everybody wants this
because it's a very it's the key to
success but they're all involved in this
tension then of how do you try to be
effortless how do you try not to try so
the first strategy is the early
Confucian strategy which I refer to as
carving and polishing strategy which is
essentially you're gonna try really hard
for a long time and if you do that
eventually the trying will fall away and
you'll be spontaneous in the right way
so you practice ritual you engage in
learning with fellow students and
eventually somehow at some point you
make the transition from trying to
having internalized these things you're
learning and being able to embody them
and
for this way the second strategy the
uncarved block or going back to nature
strategy is the daodejing or the
primitive s Taoist and they essentially
think the Confucian strategy is doomed
if you are trying to be virtuous if
you're trying to be a Confucian
gentleman you're never gonna be a
Confucian gentleman anyone trying to be
benevolent is never gonna actually be
benevolent they're just going to be this
hypocrite and so their strategy is undo
all this learning that you've been
taught so get rid of culture get rid of
learning actually physically drop out of
society so they want you to go live in
the countryside and small village and it
looks a lot like kind of 1960s hippie
movement you know back to nature and get
rid of technology get rid of all the bad
things that society has done to us
there's good points to this strategy -
one of the main insights I think of the
Daoists these early taoist is the way in
which social values social learning can
corrupt our natural preferences so we're
you know body images and advertising
teach women that they have to be
anorexic if they're attractive we're
taught that we know we need to have the
latest iPhone so you know we have
perfectly good iPhone but then we see
the new iPhone and suddenly our old
iPhone isn't good anymore and there's a
lot of good literature on this in
psychology on the hedonistic treadmill
we're never quite happy with what we
have as soon as we get it we want the
next thing and the daodejing thinks
Confucianism encourages that and the
solution to get off that hedonistic
treadmill is to just stop and go back to
nature and be simple so that's the the
uncarved block strategy and probably
which strategy is the best varies by the
situation so it probably varies from
situation to situation what you're a
particular barrier to spontaneity is in
the moment and it also probably varies
person to person so people have innate
personality differences that probably
determine which strategy is the best for
them and then also you know we've got
people are introverted you need one sort
of push and people are extroverted you
know another kind of maybe be getting
pulled in and also probably varies by
life stage so it early on in life
especially if you're trying to develop a
new skill
the carving and polishing strategy makes
the most sense and then some of these
Taoist approaches made me make more
sense when the training is done the
learning is done and you've got to learn
to just let go and let this thing you've
internalized take over and do the work
for you